George I don't care about movies the
guys like them I do so before you get in
my car and drive back to Modesto just
think about them okay and then all the
millions of other people that your
stories will someday inspire the future
of the entire world is at stake
and your own me out
[Music]
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my Star Wars legends of tomorrow
video episode 9 so much George Lucas
stuff just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet
help me George Lucas you're my only hope
this makes me so excited about legends
of tomorrow this season so much better
than season 1 almost better than the
flash right now - so there is a new
round of the reverse flash ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I have a couple updates about the
video schedule at the end of this -
first day of 3 day videos DC TV rules
from like Tuesday nights all the way to
Thursday morning so we'll see how long
my voice holds out
but number 10 is just a basic premise of
the episode a George Lucas episode the
reason the writers said they chose us
specifically is because so many of them
so many people in Hollywood are inspired
by George Lucas's accomplishments by the
movies that he's made so they wove that
into the narrative where the characters
were so inspired by him that they lost
their powers because the timeline had
changed and he never made those movies
it was just a great nod to that but
there was a lot of deep mythology in the
episode - so number nine we get
backstory on the spear of destiny and
what happened to rip hunter at the end
of that first episode when he scattered
them all across time just to protect
them so what happened is is he been
hiding a shard of the spear of destiny
just a single shard not the entire staff
itself grab the time matrix sort of
reprogramming his reality gave him a new
personality basically changed him as a
person from the ground up but if you've
watched Doctor Who there's this
character called Clara that gets
fractured all across space-time so there
are a bunch of different versions of her
existing in different time periods so
that seems like what's happened to rip
hunter because we see him show up during
colonial times in this outfit here so
number eight is they continue on their
treasure hunt like their Goonies
treasure hunt to form the spear of
destiny we'll probably meet different
versions of rip hunter that have
different shards of the spear itself but
you do get that basic set up at the end
of the episode they have the medallion
and it's very Raiders of the Lost Ark
where you have the staff with the
medallion on the top that's what they're
going for it was a very
Lucas type episode so of course the
MacGuffin is one of the MacGuffin from a
George Lucas movie number seven is this
huge mind trip - it gets super meta
because citizen Steel claims the term
Legion of Doom taking inspiration from a
hanna-barbera cartoon which is the Super
Friends cartoon in real life that he is
talking about so when he says he pulled
it from a cartoon that means that the
Justice League has existed on television
in earth ones history so that just blows
your mind you're like wait a minute
where did they get the inspiration for
that like do they create those fictional
characters is there a version of
Superman Batman Aquaman that actually
exists on this earth so it's just meant
to throw you for a loop there's always
been hints that the Batman characters
exist in this universe that Superman
exists like the joke about Felicity's
codename Oracle already being taken so
Oliver already knows about Barbara
Gordon and the fact that they have the
Hall of Justice on the flash now it's
just like another hangar that's near
STAR Labs so they're making Super
Friends on the TV show Justice League
style Hall of Justice that's what it's
called on the Super Friends cartoon in
citizen steel himself as a child watched
the cartoon makes me so happy that he
dropped that Easter egg but you guys can
let me know what you think that means
for those characters in this universe
number six you get the actual backstory
on the spear of destiny
the spear that pierced the site of
Christ the Centurions medallion they got
the blood on it that empowered it the
difference between rewriting reality in
rewriting time using basic time-travel
so you rewrite reality it's permanent
and it doesn't cause any time quakes
like you wouldn't know anything was
different the time travel changes the
time quakes that they explained take a
while to set in so they have time to fix
them so changing reality very very bad
but my number 5 was actually damian
darhk-- in merlin throughout the entire
episode they were having more fun than
anyone else i totally loved the way they
wrote them they were way funnier they're
just casually breezing down the sidewalk
Merlyn talking about all the fun stuff
that he wants to check out when they're
done killing all those people in 60s
Hollywood blows past the guard without
missing a step to stabbing him they were
so good in this episode the elevator
music
Rancic wait I will be so bummed out if
these characters aren't around in season
3 like it's much better overall all the
characters are better all of the writing
the structure of the episodes everything
is better but really it's the villains
that I think are making the difference
so number 4 the most hilarious thing
about the episode wasn't so much the
George Lucas stuff it was the way rip
hunters play was making fun of season 1
of legends of tomorrow the way he was
saying Vandal Savage wasn't a scary
enough villain is basically the writers
making fun of season 1 making fun of
themselves so it's a big eye winking
from behind the camera it was so good
but obviously you have all the George
Lucas stuff that was going on so there
were a lot of specific George Lucas call
outs but number 3 all the George Lucas
Easter eggs so there was so much stuff
happening around his character like
really obvious stuff when Adam was like
okay I got to get my Han Solo on now or
they were talking about Raiders of the
Lost Ark the actual movie itself Howard
the Duck they totally burned that at the
end of the episode the fact that rip
gives him the spear of destiny but he
throws all the props down the garbage
chute into the garbage chute flyboy I'm
going to ask you a question and your
life depends on it
where is the city dump but just a way
that they have to convince George Lucas
to go back to film school in believe in
himself
I want to make movies so that they can
get their powers back but Dixon has
probably one of the best lines in the
episode she gets the Princess Leia life
where she says George Lucas you're our
only hope
number two was the trash compactor
pulled right out of Star Wars then they
get into the big trash yard fight where
the reverse-flash shows up always busy
but always on time just making you
wonder where he was they're teasing a
little bit of tension in the Legion of
do they're going to start fighting with
each other pretty soon but you get the
sense that the reverse-flash has been on
some side mission that only he knows
about that they might address in a
future episode
but they'll probably also address on the
flash TV show because I'm expecting him
to go back before the end of the season
even if it's only for a little bit and
they tease that the black flash would be
coming on all the shows meaning that he
will appear on legends of tomorrow
probably coming for the reverse-flash
himself typically the black flash only
goes after other speedsters so it's not
like he'd be going after Merlin or
damian darhk-- when he came back but my
number one was rip hunter through the
entire episode the actor Arthur Darvill
is so much better this season than he
was in the first season I feel like them
giving him a different personality in
the way that Tom Cavanaugh is a
different character each season on the
flash really helped him out because he's
actually this really well trained really
good dramatic actor but a lot of his
season 1 stuff just felt really bland
really vanilla so this version of rip
hunter is so much more fun than season 1
rip hunter but I know I haven't
addressed the heatwave stuff which was a
big runner in the episode so he thinks
that he's been hallucinating Captain
cold but really it's just him working
through his emotions it's his
subconscious just speaking out to him
but it took them a while to get there so
they go through all these different
steps trying to mess with heatwaves head
scanning it like this can rip hunters
they even do brain surgery on him that
was one of the funniest moments in the
episode I find making great what the
hell are you doing
brain surgery will look like which is a
great episode I know a lot of you are
like did you like flash better did you
like legends better which was the
stronger episode I still like flash
better but that's only because I like
the characters better the legend story
was a little more epic just because of
the stuff they're dealing with the spear
of destiny the flash episode was more
about Wally West fitting into the team
and then figuring out a plan for
defeating savat are so all the DC shows
sort of move at their own pace you have
to remember that legends of tomorrow
only has 17 episodes while the flash
arrow Supergirl they all have 23
episodes so their story tends to get
stretched out just a little bit more so
let me know what was you guys favorite
moments from the episode what do you
think that the reverse-flash was doing
when he wasn't helping out the Legion of
Doom like he was off doing something
else that was super secret what's going
to happen tonight just an update on the
schedule is I'll post my arrow episode
video next then I'll probably do a
legends of tomorrow Legion of Doom
trailer video and then after that I'll
try to figure things out there's going
to be some more Star Wars Episode 8
posting but there's supposed to be a
special Marvel announcement it might
just be for Kingdom Hearts so if there's
something really big I'll do a video for
that too
congratulations to the new flash ring
giveaway winner
Brian Riley please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there'll be a new
round in my arrow video that I'll post
later tonight but new arrow coming later
tonight black siren get hype it's going
to be awesome well you guys wait for
that suppose you can click here for last
night's flash episodes you can click
here for the flash trailer for next
week's episode thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five see
you in the next video